all right boom here we go we're gonna
jump right into a death by 1,000 cuts
we're gonna talk about how to stay
focused we're gonna talk about how to
push distractions to the side and
eradicate them so that you can maximize
your creative endeavoring into the world
I want to shout out first the Sam Evans
for introducing me to this idea of death
by 1,000 cuts it's fascinating how its
creativity and how we're gonna unpack
these distractions and how to get
through them you only get 30,000 days to
live
two and a half billion seconds or heart
beats it's a short life you've got to
build create climb influence and be
empowered at your fullest potential in
this world
alright another huge personal on a shout
out here is Reid Hoffman and
blitzscaling prioritizing speed over
efficiency climbing up the hierarchy
gaining power and making influence so so
crucial okay let's get to the
distractions so distraction number one
cell phones cell phones are a hidden
parasite in civilization all of these
are but specifically cell phones are
hidden parasite we don't even know how
to keep our cell phones off for extended
periods of time and I mean days at a
time if not weeks so that we can fully
creatively engage our mind and what's
built up in there with its environment
and actually build and create and do so
cell phones tips for how to stay focused
and not be distracted to keep your cell
phone on silent all the time delete all
non-utility apps delete all your social
media apps turn off all your
notifications on your phone every single
last notification turn them all off I
should never get a notification power
off your phone all day long go for
periods of time practicing that and see
what it looks like and how it feels like
turn on your phone for rare outbound use
and there's that key rare you can use
your phone powered on send the one
message send the one phone call send the
one email use your Google Maps or use an
uber or whatever you got to do but but
listen to the podcast while you're
walking
do what you need in that sense or don't
and just enjoy the ambiance of the
environment but rare rare outbound use
is so crucial there don't reply to
people stop replying to people hustle
focus and execute I'll get more to who
specifically I think is best for us to
be replying to but don't reply practice
that it's not it's not your fault for
not replying
it's your divine potential being fully
executed and impacting more people and
staying focused okay moving on to the
second biggest parasite social media is
a massive parasite it is so much noise
and so little signal and it's becoming
harder and harder to parse for the truth
because there's way too much dumping of
noise and lies and gluttony for greed
and corruption and control people want
to control other humans and that's why
people just click right away and post
and they don't even critically think
anymore they just go and go and go you
got to slow down you have to analyze
tons of different sources and
perspectives on things social media is
not the place for that so when you use
social media post and get off so go post
disseminate your ideas only disseminate
ideas that are powerful that are true
that are your essence that you've done
tons of research on that you are
professional in that you care about
teaching other people teaching children
teaching adults about and empowering
this global harmony that we so
desperately need consume no social media
rarely you can consume an educational
video let's say that you find
specifically needed for your knowledge
base but never aim to never consume
social media it is massively a
distraction
I call it algorithmic cancer they're
manipulating there's so much noise so
little signals so much lack of critical
thought and so many echo chambers just
get out of the social media sphere only
use it to disseminate ideas that
another massive part of the death by
1,000 cuts and we all get those little
when you turn off your notifications you
don't but before you you turn off your
notifications you get those little
messages from all the social platforms
that are trying to reel you in over and
over again to come and use their again
they our advertising models are tied to
the attention economy for now all right
let's go to three people this can be
harsh at times right but we're gonna
talk about how to actually leverage
culture in the right way but culture has
become cancerous for creative
endeavoring in many ways so many people
are rushing to the bars rushing to the
clubs going to brunch going to movies
and they're lacking the time that they
need to just be away from people away
from these one on one one on two and
three and four person conversations
where we're just so often just going to
be a part of something that we don't
even want to be a part of we'd rather be
at home reading learning watching
creating writing making videos making
content actually engineering building
designing things into our world that
bring other people value that bring us
value that bring us actualization our
family's value our community's value
enough of being distracted to this
extent
enough of the pointless calls meetings
texts and emails think about it when
you're having these one-on-one
conversations it's a one-on-one
conversation that is lost example if you
do a one-on-one conversation that's
recorded like on our show then you can
have potential reach of thousands tens
of thousands even potentially millions
or more people if you do things like
focus on creating the content outward
instead of just losing it in these
one-on-ones the time that you spend
writing out a text or an email think
about it you can sometimes spend 15
minutes writing these things and then it
only gets seen by one person for a
couple for a minute and then it's gone
and it's done forever you could spend
that 15 minutes compounded so many other
ways to spend so think about that the
neural real estate is limited for now
pre ability to connect and
he just fully tied to everything but
it's limited for now biologically that
means that whenever we're doing this
communication with a one-on-one versus
we're doing a communication one-to-many
1 disseminating our ideas that we're
leveraging our ability to purse to
potentially disseminate mimetics out to
more people and influence more people
that way with their ideas and our
thoughts this is a brain muscle that
needs rest for creative thought that
means that our brain is like a muscle
when you're constantly using your brain
all 16 hours while you're awake and then
the 8 hours you sleep and then you use
it all 16 hours while you're awake
that is so harmful to repeat over and
over again you're not giving your brain
time to rest like a muscle and it needs
that for example when you just stay
silent and you put your phone in your
laptop and everything that you're doing
to the side and you go on a walk outside
and you just maybe you sit down and
close your eyes for a bit maybe you're
absorbing new stimuli on this walk again
you're gonna have these novel
Interdisciplinary firing and wiring of
new thoughts and new ways of perceiving
the world that you can integrate into
your ideas you have to understand that
neuroscience your brain needs that time
in order to creatively develop its
thinking and make these novel
connections between areas of your mind
and between ideas alright so not just
only not talk to people at all right we
have nuance here so the nuance is that
when you do network you have to network
with the top of the hierarchy of the
network with rapid climbers this is so
crucial this means that when you go out
somewhere and that you're again you're
going to this brunch or you're going to
this networking event that you have to
know that if this and brunch or this
networking event doesn't have great
influencers doesn't have really powerful
minds in the field that you're very
interested in that you want to provide
them value get value from them as well
that don't go stay and find other people
build new friend groups keep finding the
rapid climbers in the hierarchy keep
going and pursuing what is most
meaningful to you by going to the top
as possible so you can create as much
influence as you can with your ideas all
right next up next up is the other junk
okay so this is so crucial this is the
other junk of the thousand cuts you get
the thousand cuts with your cell phone
and notifications a thousand cuts of
social media thousand cuts with the
branches and the Netflix's and all the
other stuff and then here's the other
junk when you focus so much of our time
on things like alcohol and cigarettes
and all these other drugs that are out
there cannabis and psychedelics which
have asterisks because in very rare use
you can use cannabis psychedelics
especially if you need it medically but
remember how just distract if things
like going out and just doing these
drugs all the time how often do you
actually focus and execute on what
matters to you
think about how much time we waste on
pour and how much time we waste on
eating junk food I'm time we waste and
how much that affects our health on
eating refined sugar as well not moving
our bodies we gotta move our bodies we
have to exercise we have to stretch
that's what actually gets our blood
flowing it gets the creative thoughts
rolling it gets us more mobile and we
live longer that way we have to eat
healthy too this is so so crucial for
our health and for to not die by these
thousand cuts again you gotta sleep got
to get that eight hours of sleep
it's so crucial not only is dreamland a
really important place for you to go and
lucidly dream and and really understand
what's happening in those eight hours
the one third of our life we spend there
but also you got to get out to nature
gotta meditate at this as well so we
focus on those things simultaneously as
you're focusing on in the creative
execution lots of time on creative
execution lots of time away from cell
phones away from social media away from
the cancerous algorithms of culture re
and then just in summary again we got to
eradicate all these distractions we got
to have long periods of focus and
execution speed over efficiency pump
pump pump pump out your work get more
work out get more things done that you
love that you're super passionate about
building climb up
hierarchy gain power make influence
build up the civilization design the
civilizational protocols that you want
to see in place you got to build them
you got to build them in yourself their
self work you got to build them in your
family and your community and inspire
others to do that and then in the world
we can get there together everyone stay
focused don't die by these thousand cuts
turn off that cell phone turn off that
social media get away from the cancerous
cultural algorithms that exist in all
the different facets and get executing
get blitzscaling go go go build build
build I love you all so much thank you
for tuning in I'm Alan socking a host of
simulation and remember support the
endeavors that you believe in the
artists and entrepreneurs that you think
are building the future support them
around you our links are below join us
as well give us your thoughts about the
video below much love go and build the
future everyone hustle focus much love
we'll see you soon
peace